see ya
welcome to our first demo walkthrough
for total war Warhammer what you're
about to see is a scripted version of
the battle for black fire pass a
set-piece quest battle between the
Empire and the greenskins the game is
very much a work in progress at the
stage but we hope you'll enjoy having a
look at how it's all coming together now
is the time men of the Empire two unites
for the orcs gather beyond the pass a
war buff straws to him all that is foul
and all court beyond imagining as Sigma
thoughts troll shall we we will become
part of the legend we will wake the orcs
from our door and only when this is done
when our nation has healed
shall I take up
for the Empire
so that was Emperor Karl Franz giving
his rousing pre-battle speech he's one
of the game's legendary Lords so he's a
powerful general and a mighty warrior in
his own right playing a campaign as the
Empire unlocked this particular quest
battle as Karl Franz levels up so the
impasse fielding a lot of artillery in
this battle but it's worth noting that
you won't just be able to recruit all of
this stuff right from the start the game
there are quite a few late game units on
show here today and the same goes for
spells as well you'll see a lot of kind
of late-game high-level stuff
now as we approach the green-skinned
line you can see just how different
these two races are the armies from
Warhammer Fantasy battles give us so
much diversity to work with the playable
race in the game are going to look and
play really really differently in both
campaign and battle
and looking out over Blackfyre pass for
a second here you can just see the kind
of fantastical landscapes that we've
never been able to do before in a total
war game and this is just one
geographical part of the old world this
is the green skin race leader grim gore
Ironhide he's accompanied by the
Immortals his hard-as-nails band the
Black Hawk bodyguards he's also brought
an aux Aemon into battle with him so
we'll see him throwing some spells
around in a bit
so these snickering little Copland's are
Manning a doom divert catapult they can
see a goblin fanatic they're climbing
into the mechanism eagerly with his
homemade wings strapped to his arms and
as it fires you can opt to take
first-person control of the doom diver
and pilot him to his doom now it's a
pretty wild ride but once you get a hang
of it you can really get proficient
so that's another spellcaster right here
this is a goblin shame and you can see
him riding his wolf there so he cast
spells from the little wah magical law
so there's a bit of a flanking
counter-attack lining up here from the
empire we've got some range cavalry up
front they're in the shape of outriders
and pistol ears coming up behind them we
have the noble Imperial Knights to the
rights guard and a unit of Demi Grif
Knights
these are super heavy shot cavalry on
vicious monstrous mounts so you can
withstand a real pounding so they're
really useful in longer melee
engagements
so the Goblet chairman here has just
cast a spell called the curse of the bad
rune now it's pretty powerful impressive
looking high end spell but it's well if
they think that we don't want magic to
be to Opie they'll have a limited pool
of magic to use in every battle that
recharges over time according to various
factors but basically you're going to
have to pick and choose just when to
cast high-level spells like this we
don't want magic to totally dominate the
game it's more of a kind of useful
supporting tool so the Demi's are going
in now and you can see just the
beautiful handcrafted animations at work
here and you can see that throughout the
battle one thing that we're still
working on is cavalry versus cavalry
impacts and in fact impacts across the
board so what we're aiming for is seems
like this to be much more punchy with
more physical reactions from the cavalry
let's drop in short we want to make a
real kind of spectacle in these
engagements
it's appalling down the line here you
can see just how dynamic our infantry
charges have become but units leaping
into the fray defenders physically
bracing for impact you've got a oe
attacks going off from large characters
that's grim Gor Ironhide they're getting
stuck in with these big magical axe
and in go the trolls the end of the line
here now monstrous infantry like this
have have you know lots and lots of hit
points they can meet our ton of damage
of those big attacks as well and these
guys are also as you can see partial to
puking acid pile all over their enemies
[Applause]
a bit of aerial combat going on here
between deathclaw in the wild now if you
gain mastery the sky isn't battle like
this you can then use the
maneuverability of your flying units to
strike pretty much anywhere on the
battlefield
as the wife comes down here to attack me
state troopers you can see how each of
these big monsters has some really
spectacular combat animations it really
brings them to life and gives them tons
of character
[Applause]
now these are two of the Empire's hero
characters this is the warrior priests
and just beyond it there the witch
hunter heroes are essentially agents so
they can roam the campaign map perform a
number of different functions but
they're also powerful or solo warriors
in their own right and if you attach
them to an army they can then throw
themselves into combat alongside the
troops
[Music]
so this is the orc Shaymin casting one
of the spells from the big war magical
law so he's casting the foot of cork
here which is literally summoning the
orc God Cork to stamp his enemies into
the dust which is as you can see bad
news for the lumen Ark and the steam
tank nearby
and finally the Empire's celestial
wizard is summoning down the comet of
Cass Endora
so thanks for watching the demo and this
really just scratches the surface to the
incredible Warhammer world we'll be
asking you to conquer to catch all the
latest gameplay and feature reveals
subscribe to our YouTube channel or
follow us on Facebook
you